hi in this video we are going to walk
you through a demo
of contact center ai that helps states
and local governments roll out covet
vaccines
effectively hello i'm a virtual agent
for the state kobit 19 response center
i can help you determine when you will
be eligible for the kobit 19 vaccine
and where you can get vaccinated how can
i help you
is the vaccine free
yes the kovid 19 vaccines will be
available at no cost
what else can i help you with do covet
19 vaccines contain
animal based ingredients
no the manufacturing process of the
moderna and pfizer bioentech covid19
vaccines are cell-free and both vaccines
contain no human or animal products
preservatives or adjuvants and utilize
no ingredients of human or animal origin
what else can i help you with am i
eligible for the covet vaccine
the state's prioritization strategy for
vaccine distribution is designed to
ensure early vaccination of the most
vulnerable citizens
in order to determine your eligibility i
will need to ask you a series of
questions
let's get started are you a healthcare
worker in the icu
ed or ems a long-term care facility
worker who regularly interacts with
residents or a high-risk long-term
care facility patient no
okay are you a first responder a teacher
or school staff
a public health worker an essential
frontline worker that regularly
interacts with the public
a long-term care facility patient or an
individual in the general population at
high risk due to comorbidities and
health conditions
no
got it are you either over 65 years old
or under 65 years old with high risk
comorbidities and health conditions
no
okay we're down to the final question
now
tell me are you an essential worker of
any kind
no
thank you i have all the information i
need the state has adopted a multi-phase
approach to vaccine distribution
based on your responses you are eligible
for the covid19 vaccine in phase 5.
you can find specific information about
vaccine availability in the state's
cobit 19 vaccination program document at
www.governor.state.gov
what else can i help you with where can
i get the covet 19 vaccine
i'd be glad to help with that in order
to find the closest location where you
can get a vaccination
please provide me your five digit zip
code
my zip code is one zero zero one one
got it that's one oh one one based on
this information
your closest vaccination location as
pharmacy a
at 475 6th avenue new york
what else can i help you with is there
some other location
the next location where you can get a
vaccine would be pharmacy b
at 205 8th avenue new york what else can
i help you with
actually i would prefer a hospital
okay the nearest hospital where you can
get the vaccine as medical center
see at 325 west 15th street new york
what else can i help you with i want to
talk to a representative
sure please hold while i transfer you
hello welcome to the state department of
health how can i help you
hey so i wanted to know will the vaccine
give me covet
no none of the vaccines being studied
are made of materials that can cause
disease
okay can i get any allergic reaction
from the coven 19 vaccine
that's a great question
people can have allergic reactions to
any medication
or biological products such as a
vaccine did i answer your question
um i think so thank you so much
okay thank you bye-bye right
what you just saw there was the agent
getting a recommendation
from the knowledge base for the commonly
asked questions
they did not have to look for the
information and
there's also a thumbs up or thumbs down
which can be used by the agent
to provide feedback to the system that
this response was
good this helps the agent assist to
incorporate the agent feedback
thanks for watching and if you're
looking for more details on contact
center ai solution
we have included the link below
you